a Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance an actor thought on the
testimony Thursday of the former FBI
director James Comey not what he said
that appropriately grabbed all the
headlines but what he put only in his
written testimony that never directly
came up aloud at the hearing in short
what was that again about Russian
hookers on the morning of March 30 the
president called me at the FBI Comey
wrote he described the Russian
investigation as a cloud that was
impairing his ability to act on behalf
of the country he said he had nothing to
do with Russia had not been involved
with hookers in Russia and had always
assumed he was being recorded when he in
Russia
wait what I know this was covered when
commis opening statement was released in
advance and to some degree during and
after his testimony but isn't there
something even more amiss here than has
yet to be publicly recognized you call
up a guy whom you're desperately trying
to convince to publicly clear you whom
you will later fire whom you will later
threaten with a vague claim that you may
have taped your conversations with him
and who will thus be required to talk
about what you said to him in public
venues and probably under oath and you
say something like I have not been
involved with hookers in Russia and I
always assumed I was being recorded when
in Russia seriously even in the
cascading madness of the seven months
since the election is this not just the
craziest thing ever attributed to any
President of the United States but the
craziest choice of topics ever raised by
any President of the United States is it
not evidence that within trump's
desperate obsession to get somebody to
clear him personally about Russia and
boy-oh-boy to you and I understand
Trump's desperate need to get somebody
to clear him personally about Russia
inside that does it not seem there is an
obsession within an obsession I mean
what the whole election thing isn't true
but mr. FBI director make sure you clear
me about the Russian hooker thing and
this was not even the first time he
brought it up to Comey
January 27th during the dinner the
president returned to the salacious
material I had briefed him about On
January 6 and as he had done previously
expressed his disgust for the
allegations and strongly denied the
he said he was considering ordering me
to investigate the alleged incident to
prove it didn't happen I replied that he
should give that careful thought because
it might create a narrative that we were
investigating him personally which we
weren't and because it was a very
difficult to prove a negative to be fair
as Comey said in his statement it was he
who brought this up first
he brought the steel dossier including
the Russian hypothetical hookers and all
their glory to Trump's attention when
they first met in New York on January
6th but three weeks later Kampf was
going to order Comey to disprove it
somehow to have the FBI conclude
something didn't happen and it didn't
happen in Russia and that is still one
of trumps first concerns when he phones
Comey eighty three days later he said he
had nothing to do with Russia had not
been involved with hookers in Russia and
had always assumed he was being recorded
when in Russia and in a speech in
Australia overnight between commis
statement and commis testimony the
former Director of National Intelligence
James clapper said he had telephone
Trump on January 11th to encourage him
to stop comparing the American
intelligence community to the Nazis and
quoting clapper in the speech ever
transactional he simply asked me to
refute the infamous dossier which I
couldn't and wouldn't do I am NOT for a
moment suggesting this detail from this
rancid presidency is as important as all
the times commies words at the hearing
supported accusations of obstruction of
justice against Trump nor commis joy at
the prospect that there might be tapes
of his meetings with Trump nor his
implication that Trump is under
investigation now by the special counsel
nor certainly the weight that commis
testimony added to the evidence
necessitating Trump's immediate
impeachment not even Trump's attorney
misspelling president in his response to
the hearing and thus calling him present
trunk but it's not just that there's
something wrong here there's something
wrong here when commis opening statement
was first released Trump attorney Mark
Kassovitz issued a forty-three word
victory lap including the president
feels completely vindicated and before
the paint was dry on that statement from
that attorney another statement
came from another Trump attorney commis
statement released today needs to be
carefully scrutinized Michael Cohen
asserted as his testimony claims the
president was concerned about the
dossier it must be noted that the
dossier has been debunked even by the
author himself
Christopher Steele well except a
Christopher Steele did not debunk his
dossier he wrote as he submitted it that
a lot of it was unverified that it was
raw intelligence that needed further
investigation and B what the hell the
dossier again that's what you want to
underline after a statement from the
fired
FBI director about how he was to testify
under oath two facts that could
conceivably end a presidency a dossier
you just put the dossier and the Russian
hypothetical hookers back under the
public nose again
why because Comey only referenced them
twice somehow that wasn't enough for you
why because you wanted to make sure
every news organization in the world has
to bring up the Steele dossier and the
hookers even the news organizations who
never mentioned them in the first place
I mean what's hidden within the Steele
dossier that could conceivably be more
damaging to Trump then you know
impeachment or evidence of treason or or
both what could it contain that on
January 27th and March 30th and June 7th
the president and then one of his
attorneys are seemingly more concerned
with it than anything else what could
possibly be in the Steele dossier
well Russian hypothetical hookers move
over Richard Nixon before all this ends
I am NOT a crook may be replaced in
presidential lore with I am NOT a john
resist piece